[Music]
[Applause]
bringing Ray Allen the former Yukon
husky Hall of Famer of course how
excited are you about your alma mater
there
extremely extremely uh first of all good
morning Dan
um this tournament uh season has
certainly been uh very entertaining uh
on both sides men and women and uh just
to see you you look at the the final
four you look at the bracketing uh the
ranking of all the teams uh there's I
think a 9C fifth seed and then four and
five uh it truly to me it shows that the
parody in in college basketball that
anybody could win at any given moment
and when you think about the tournament
the way it's set up it gives everybody a
chance because
that ranking just like for kids in high
school means nothing you know once we
throw that ball up in the air who wants
it the baddest is is Ultimate is going
to come out on top
how is the tournament changed since you
played
not at all uh just from my vantage point
uh I talked to my kids about uh
traveling between
um region tournament sites uh the travel
uh throughout America at that time some
of the for us we always say we this is
when we truly feel like a professional
athlete because there are times when we
were on the road for 10 11 games uh I'll
tell you a story real quick so we played
in in 95 against uh UCLA in Oakland you
know after then Oakland Coliseum and we
stayed at the Hilton by the airport
so we get beat by UCLA you know they go
on and win the national championship
that year and we have been on the road
because we got send out west I think
we're number two in our bracket so we I
think we played in Utah and then we
moved further on to to Oakland
so we lose that game everybody's you
know somewhat
actually happy to go home because we
have been gone for 11 days you know you
figure you think everybody'd be sad but
we were happier because we had been
we're not used to being away from home
for so long we get back to the hotel
and somebody broke into our hotel and
stole all of our stuff
so to add insult to injury uh I had to
wear coach Calhoun's sweatsuit on the
plane back to Connecticut
so they took your uniforms and
everything or did they just take your
gear your your personal stuff just all
my personal stuff everything had packed
they had rifle through my bags anything
that I had you figure I was gone for 11
days so I had basically everything that
I owned all my CDs kids that's the thing
that spins around
um so everything that it was a value to
me at the time you know it was stolen
from you so I guess it's a story to tell
now it didn't really matter in the long
term uh you stayed three years
yeah you were playing now
would you be one and done
uh were you ready to be one and done I I
don't think I was ready uh even even
three years at UConn I was having such a
blast that's the thing that we lose
sight of and I think kids forget once
going professional is great you get to
make money but
in college it's an experience that I
hope kids would kind of cherish and and
want to experience uh just being a
Collegiate athlete being on a campus and
having an opportunity to make mistakes
uh building bonds and and long-term
relationships because I think about my
college teammates yeah we go to each
other's weddings uh see each other over
Summers you know play golf together I
think that's the most extensive network
of friends that you'll ultimately end up
having as those you went to college with
are you going to go to the Final Four
uh that I'm planning on it I'm looking
forward to it I think you should wear
your uniform
my uniform was one a Yukon
oh well you got it yeah I know you got
them and you got your uh Seattle
SuperSonics hoodie on yeah I like that
when are they getting a team they got to
be getting a team when Vegas gets a team
right
I think Seattle should be next on the
docket yeah that's also rich in that
region take about when you think about
Seattle think about all the players now
in the league coming from Seattle
um if you think about the guys that
played that came from Seattle I think if
you go back to those those mid 90s
Seattle teams you know with Gary Payton
and Sean Kemp and Della strength and
Percy Hawkins all those guys they grew
up a a generation of players it helped
bring basketball to that region you know
in such a strong manner so now those
kids are growing up so the latest you
know you got uh uh band Caro
um you know now young guy out of Seattle
um
um uh Devonte uh out of a plan for the
Hawks uh just so many great young
talents that have come out of Seattle
area and and that's a tribute to having
that franchise in that community and I
think most people look at it as a as a a
franchise or a professional team but
it's a community resource you know kids
look up to those players those players
visit the schools in the community you
see them on the streets like it just it
helps kids dream or aspire to be greater
than that which they see in their in
their communities I'm talking to Ray
Allen the Hall of Famer two-time NBA
champ I'll give you a vote for the MVP
who are you voting for in the NBA uh
uh I I will say I'm voting for up to
what I've seen I'm going with embiid
did it change recently
um the NBA so it's it's difficult to put
uh your finger on it because oftentimes
when you're looking at
uh these different pockets of of the
Season you know each 10 game stretch
something different happens so you start
to think over the period of 82 games who
is the most consistent and on top of
that which team is the most successful
so I like to think that it's a difficult
equation because any year it could be
two or three guys that you can
legitimately say as the MVP
um but then you also have to give the
edge to that guy I think the ultimate
um uh
understanding is if you remove that
player from the team how good would that
team be which it's a difficult uh idea
to process because
you know a good team still has other
players on them just as well that can
help you win a championship but the MVP
removed from that team is also
you you lose that guy and you definitely
won't be where you are so you know
jokish is definitely a close second
because Denver's
second or third in the in the NBA and um
in in in in wins right now or in the
Western Conference at least yeah I would
probably still give it to Joker because
if you take him away they don't have an
All-Star
you know Porter you know Jamal is a good
player those aren't All-Stars uh embiid
still has harden and Harden's leading
the NBA an assist and still is a great
player uh Giannis has a couple of
All-Stars holiday and Middleton are both
uh I think the Joker has done more with
less on a consistent basis and they have
the best record in the west but I think
there's vote voter fatigue here Ray yeah
and right
yeah I agree with you you when you think
about uh Denver most people when you
talk about who votes for for the MVP you
know Denver a lot of times they get lost
in the sauce because they are out west
um
jokish won two times already so now he's
almost a victim of his own success
I do believe
just when you're throwing bee's name in
there you know even with Hardin embed
has had some some big games he's been
very dominant he's been very Unstoppable
uh the one thing that you have to also
protect against when you make these
decisions
is uh the league is a very stat-driven
League uh in today's era so you have to
also be careful of just looking at a
guy's stats and saying oh he had this
many points this many rebounds this many
assists a lot of times it is an eye test
too
looking at a player and just seeing
because sometimes
when you see a guy on the floor that
plays effects you know the ability to
create double teams to the ability to
just change the game just for being and
I don't even think it's a plus or minus
thing it's just the it's that that aura
that that player has when they're out on
the floor the confidence it gives uh to
their their teammates and you know
similar to us
I've had that I'm sure that effect on on
teams but then when I was in Boston kg
was that type of player because we were
so much better with him on the floor
because he did intimidate other players
so that too has an effect on how did he
intimidate
uh do you need to pull up some video
clip right now well thank you but but is
it because he's yelling at them I know
his play would be intimidating but well
I think all of the above okay because he
he I think won his his stature because
you know being seven feet tall and being
long and then and then you know
screaming and yelling and intimidating
um just dunking the balls and screaming
like a lot of younger kids that come to
the league that that intimidation you
got to remember I think about when I
came into the league the guys that
intimidated me just by me being on the
floor with them MJ Mitch Richmond Reggie
Miller uh excuse me Clyde Drexler uh the
list goes on but how would they
intimidate you was it just Talent
uh well yeah Talent you gotta remember
too you when you when you feel like
you're in a situation where you in in
some instances when you're young you
feel like you don't belong because you
watch these these guys play for so many
years of your life
to now you're on the floor with them
like you you when I first played against
MJ I I'm still I'm listening to the to
their theme song when they run out onto
the floor and I I I ask myself how did I
get in the TV
like I remember sitting at home on the
couch and you hear this the running of
the bulls song comes on and now I'm
sitting on a court live like I just
somebody just snapped the finger
so you start to when you start thinking
that you're like wow am I even do I even
belong here so I think that trepidation
I think it it does rest in everybody's
Minds when they first get into the
league and then there's a point where
you have to say I'm one of these guys
like I can compete against them but he
actually also has to guard me as well
but did Jordan know that you were
intimidated by him early no no I I had
never met Jordan up to that point so
when when this was a preseason game so
when he came out of court he said
congratulations welcome to the NBA and
the first thing I thought of was like
wow this man knows my name and that was
the first stamp for me of uh
haven't arrived because this the
greatest player of all times he knows
who I am
in this game of basketball and the thing
that I've learned yeah but what did he
do to you in the game
well it was preseason so not not a lot I
I have to add that I scored nine points
in the first quarter and
I didn't know coach took me out of the
game and I didn't play anymore and at
that time I was like I couldn't believe
it I was like I thought I was about to
score 30. uh and I didn't realize like
coach was already cool with me he knew
what I brought to the table so then uh I
sat for most of the game he wanted to
see what these other guys could do so it
was a certainly one of those moments
where I learned you know about minutes
you know and and then I had this
conversation uh we were in preseason
game and it happened to be against
Minnesota and it was myself Uh Kevin
Garnett and Stephon Marbury and we were
in the locker room after a game we were
somewhere in like Moline Illinois or
Fargo North Dakota
and we were just discussing how we were
talking about how good we were because
we were putting up numbers in preseason
in case he looks at us and goes man you
guys aren't playing hard
they don't play harder don't don't don't
get all beside yourself thinking that
you're great yet you know these guys are
just going through the motions and I did
learn that like it's just kind of a
filling out process in the preseason all
right I have a guy that works here
Marvin and uh lifelong Yukon pen went to
UConn went to your uh basketball camp
anything else you want to tell Ray Allen
Marvin yeah Henry van Baker used to have
those celebrity tournaments those
celebrity games at the Hartford Civic
Center yeah Ray hope Camp went to all
that yeah I didn't listen to you when
you showing us to shoot emotions but big
fan
you why did you listen Marvin I don't
understand I was giving you some nuggets
and you didn't listen right he shoots
like Anthony Mason
oh that I mean see you did listen Marvel
we could have listened okay okay it's
the blueprint we need some help here Ray
because let's say UConn wins Marvin
would like to go to the parade
okay
like he wants to be in the parade
and what qualification does he have to
be in the parade well he's on my show so
he's around a great shooter who knows
basketball
and he went to UConn
what else do you need I think based on
those qualifications he definitely can
be at the parade okay okay okay
I mean what what but here's the
beautiful thing Marvin you live in
Connecticut
you went to UConn
it's
it's not really a parade in college you
just show up and you see the guys come
down go to the arena and you just sit
there and you celebrate the guys like
what more can you ask for maybe be on
stage
can't do that right okay all right
uh what do you think it's a better
chance Seattle gets an NBA team or
Marvin would be in the parade he'd be
part of the ceremony
hmm I I would have to say that uh
Marvin sorry you you yeah yeah I was
gonna get a team before you get on that
Marv I tried I mean I'm asking Ray right
here I'm trying Hey no it's all good I'm
talking to Ray Allen so I can quit the
show I can do all that right now oh
you're quitting the show no no I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry don't quit no no I I
won't my bills my bills come every month
you know what I'm gonna get a hold of uh
Shabazz Napier he could probably help
you get you know somebody like that who
could get he's got some juice there what
do you think
[Laughter]
do not answer the phone if Marvin calls
okay so sorry Shabazz Napier's not gonna
take your call either mark Khalid
al-amin can get you into that parade
Ray good to talk to you good luck with
you with your husky sorry great to talk
to you let's do it all right that's Ray
Allen yeah two-time NBA champ I love
that hoodie